il y avait trois rangs s'est battu trois
fois et après je me suis fait respecter
pendant mes deux dernières années il
faut - il en parlant de ça il a gagné un
combat contre mike tyson chez pas
populaire je suis pas bien c'est aussi
je suis apprécié des gens dire ça comme
ça je me trop exagérer les personnes qui
ont du style mal j'en connais pas trop
parce que ici tout le monde s'habille en
jogging baskets ils ont le style clonage
le même style que tout le monde
par exemple à la rentrée tout le monde
s'habille bien tout le monde était
habillé pareil ça fait moi je me suis
démarqué
j'ai mis des bottes en cuir avec un jean
slim une veste en fourrure c'est ça que
je dis faut se démarquer faut créer son
propre style sous le mont dhabi pareil
et moi je trouve qu'il n'ya que moi qui
sors du loup sans vouloir me vanter
c